we've got a robot arm down the hall that
we use to do plant reconstruction maybe
that's for another video well should we
go and see what it can we look at it or
we might be able to look at it it'll be
messy because um you know it's PhD
student course a daughter might be look
to my concert Oh Jimmy spends a lot of
time in the gym here we go so this is in
some sense as in prototype stage so you
know lots of cables around but you can
see it's basically taking pictures of
the plant and actually fact the the
camera here is static and at the moment
the turntable is moving and this is our
10 PhD student Jonathan the way that
this works is that the camera will try
and move to get the best possible view
of which items move out the way there
well let's just see what those says do
not touch any of the equipment yeah I
come here and move it about when he's
not here just to annoy him so but what
it will do is it will move to try and
get the best view of the plant it can
some plants of different sizes so you're
going to have to move backwards to get
them into shot some of them are smaller
with more intricate leaves and you go
try moving closer so this is still a
work in progress but it's something
we're working towards space carving is
one of the things we're examining here
but we're obviously doing a lot of other
stereo matching and multi-view stereo as
well we talked about stereo matching so
we've got some cameras and we've
calibrated them we know where they are
in three dimensions and then we can use
a feature correspondence between
different images to work out how far
away something is or lots of things in
the scene and we can begin to build up a
disparity map now there are lots of ways
of doing this today we're going to talk
about one that's slightly unusual that
does see quite a lot of use in in
research in academia and in plant
science and things like that where I
obviously do a bit of work and that's
called space carving space carving is
the idea of starting up with in a sense
a big lump of clay working out where you
know your object is not and cutting that
clay away until you get something that
kind of resembles what your object is
supposed to be except it's based only on
what you can see in two-dimensional
images so I mean a good example would be
if I give you it if I show you this
right what's that
yeah so see it's not it's not a trick
question okay well that's obviously a
it's a silly negate with some it is a
mug like I send it with a handle on it
which is I don't know what the shape of
right but I think if you can't absolute
you can't actually be sure okay you've
only got one camera you're looking at
the mr. vision this mug could go off for
one meter backwards into this wall and
you wouldn't absolutely be sure but it
didn't do that apart from your intuition
about what it is okay and in the fact
that you're human you know it's a mug
and that's sorry just because I'm
handheld and not on the tripod I can
move side to side which move side to
side okay so one of the ways that we
work out what shape an object is truly
is we move around it and see it from
other angles okay or we rotate the
object and find out it isn't in fact to
me too long because I'll just hit myself
in the head okay so but the point is
until we see it from a different angle
we can't be absolutely sure now it on a
computer that's more true even because
they can't Intuit
anything today so we show them this and
they say well it's a square box with a
little circle on the end of it and
that's all they can tell us okay they
can't tell us what shape it is they
can't tell us that it's Hollow or
anything else because how would they
know how would they know but it isn't
longer this way okay unless we start to
build in some sort of rules so what
space carving does is look at this mug
and try and carve a piece of clay in
that shape okay but under the assumption
but it could go back here alright then
we turn it and go oh it doesn't and cut
that bit off and then we turn it again
and we cut that bit off and we keep
doing this until we cut off as much as
we can the more views we get the better
the result so if I draw a picture and
I'll show you so let's start with this
movie scoop which after comments on the
last video I solved so that people
wouldn't crab at me me anyway right so
this fish to my eye is a cube okay what
we're know ignore in a color and the
divots in it for now so but if I look at
it from this angle it's kind of a sort
of I'm not sure what shape that is some
kind of diamond d square e some someone
in the comments will know what shape
that is and they can say right I don't
okay the point is I don't know that it's
a cube based only on that view it's only
when I rotate it a lot of times I get to
feel what it is
so if from the side what we might have
is you might have an image now we're
assuming as well actually that we can
segment this what do you mean by segment
so work out where in the what
bits which pixels in our image are
object and which bits are the background
okay so this room is not ideal for this
okay first of all because this is quite
a tricky one to segment because it's
different colors but also because
there's books and shelves and with
computer code and things around the
place but are distracting so often when
you're using space carving you will put
a big black background or big white
background at the back so that you don't
you just not making life too difficult
for yourself for no reason other than
because you like paint right so this is
a bit like in the movies when they use a
green screen exactly like that so in the
green screen obviously lets you replace
the backdrop but if you made the green
screen have different colors on it all
you'd be doing is making your life more
difficult so I take a picture of this
from the side with a blank background
and my stereo algorithm tells me about
its kind of that shape I in my mind have
an idea of some kind of big volume of
voxels voxels are quite popular these
days due to a certain piece of software
called minecraft but voxels have been
around for a while a voxel is basically
a 3d pixel now in Minecraft you can
think of each square of land or air or
sea or whatever you've got as being a
voxel and then obviously the rules of
the game change depending on what things
are in different blocks in my work the
voxels are basically the same it's just
that we don't tend to have stone and
lava and things okay yeah I mean I'd
like to but unfortunately I was paying
to do that
so um so what we have is we have a huge
block of 3d pixels okay something like
this right I'm not going to finish the
last site just it was people just people
don't want to watch me just drawing
lines all day my point is that this
voxel down here will either have
something in it or it won't okay now
there are algorithms that have degrees
of they can do they can store things
like distances to the nearest surface
and things that it's a more complicated
versions of this but we'll just pretend
that isn't a thing for now so just just
to kind of get it's absolutely clear
that's not the Rubik's Cube you've drawn
is that like a 3d canvas or yeah that's
exactly what it is it's a big 3d image
at some point we will hope our cube will
be in it but it isn't currently okay
our cube will be someone in the middle
of this and some of these will disappear
so what we do is we project this image
which let's imagine it is intersecting
this directly right so it's not a funny
angle for now okay
this way and we say that this pixel here
is background okay so this row of pixels
here are not of interest to us and we
remove them so this gets a little bit
smaller this one same again this one
same again so you're carving them off
we're carving them off exactly right and
in actual fact what we're doing is just
setting them to zero okay or something
similar I mean actually these things are
stored in usually in an acceleration
structure like a top tree or something
like that
the letters do this a little bit more
elegantly that's got to be a different
video yeah let me about let's leave it
for a different video basically it will
be unusual to store this just as a huge
block of contiguous memory just because
it just takes a lot of RAM especially if
you're trying to do this at a high
resolution so we get rid of this one we
get rid of this one but these ones in
the middle they're part of our objects
so we know maybe we flag this one up and
this one and this one and this one that
kind of the same shape maybe yeah ish
right this is not a very high resolution
voxel volume that the point remains okay
so we we've carved this off now what you
then get is basically a sort of
triangular II cylinder in this direction
okay so it's not anywhere near I will be
scooping it so what we then do is we
rotate this or we move the either the
object or the camera and we intersect
again and then we move it again and we
intersect again and we keep chipping
away at these things and they fall off
and then we get left with something
hopefully resembles our we've cube now
this isn't actually always a case if I
draw if I draw a picture from top down
right so if we're now looking at our
rubik's cube from from above with a
camera at the side so here's my camera
all right and here's my rubik's cube
most cameras are not or for graphic
which means that they don't look in
parallel to the scene they look at an
angle they're conical shape the
projection matrices are conical so this
actually sort of squishes all of this
scene in here like this okay which
actually means that the cube is slightly
distorted this is why you get things
like bow or distortion of things what's
one of the reasons you do so the problem
is that this camera sees an image that
looks like that okay a square box inside
some background right so it carves away
but it can't carve away parallel to
these edges because it can't see
parallel to the edges so actually it
carves away like this so not only do we
not know what's in here
we also don't know what's here and
what's here now if I bring in another
camera my paper is getting quite thick
quite full of stuff so here's another
camera here this is going to come in
like this and so now my object is was
it's an sort of this bit okay so now my
object is that shape which is I still
doesn't bear any resemblance to our to
our cube at all in a literature this is
called the photo hull or the consistency
photos is ehealth so this is basically
our best guess at what the object is
based on the evidence we've seen so far
and it's interesting how far away that
is from the object we as humans in two
views of sizes up straight away thanks
to movies cube yeah one view would do it
for me but for a computer to views not
anywhere near enough so we add another
one from here and we go from the top and
we cut them out and we gradually improve
on our model but we're never going to
completely improve on it not with
perspective projection cameras which are
all cameras basically I mean if you want
to buy an orthographic lens it'll cost
you somewhere around twenty thousand
pounds and it will capture a piece of
image about this big like you know
you'll get thirty centimeters of shot
they're quite cool though
anyway we keep carving away at this and
what we'll end up with is something that
looks nearly like a cube so we probably
maybe a bit a bit of extra there and a
bit of extra there and there but we'll
get it we're getting there okay now some
objects obviously are more amenable to
miss than others but the more images we
get the better it is there's no depth
involved here at all okay we're not
worrying about that there are people who
are using RGB D cameras and that would
help this so that's red green and blue
and depth yep that's right so connect
for example or the matrix camera that we
talked about a few years ago so that has
depth information added to its RGB which
just gives you more information on
what's going on that combined with this
is quite a powerful tool but in this
case I can't afford the rate it's coming
right now so we'll just use a normal
camera and we can't wait this now the
problem is that that this to the camera
now is a circle and looks exactly the
same as that okay when you haven't got
depth information we know it's hollow
but the camera doesn't so the best we're
going to get with space carving is
something that look like looks like this
but it's completely full okay which is
which is just sort of a block because
how could we possibly carve into this
when we can't see through it and that's
one of the problems in the literature
for example if you can sort
implants a lice plant that has very flat
leaves will work fine because you can
carve away sort of parallel to the
surface of a leaf I mean actually
there's a lot about problems with Vice
parts are very very thin but if you use
it like a tomato plant that's got a big
curved leaf surface you end up with this
big block of leaf where you don't really
know where the leaf surface is because
it's somewhere in that block and we
couldn't carve away anymore and that
that's a bit of a problem so the plant
that you were looking at a minute ago on
the turntable is kind of one of our test
plants it's actually quite hard because
it's quite a it's got some leads coming
out aside but really it's just a big
mass in the middle which space carving
of course is not it's not well it's not
capable of dealing with it's not really
suited for it's not like it's suited for
dealing with things that are quite
sparse or simple primitives now in our
case we're using space carving to work
out where the camera should be and then
we're using more free more detailed 3d
methods to do actual surface
reconstruction so it's just a means to
an end
but it gives you a proof of concept but
you have how it work so this is the
actual model you can see we found all
the leaves they're not hugely
high-resolution because we didn't
attempt to space carpets at high
resolution you can imagine also there's
quite a memory overhead that high
resolution you go and you can also see
the middle of this plant is kind of
useless because it's just very busy from
a silhouette you can't gain a lot of
information about what shape it is yeah
it's a little bit like Lego a Lego model
of it or or a Minecraft model of it
asthma details really on the edges you
know and then in the middle it's not
what you can do it depends on the object
you're taking my jungle plants obviously
work quite well so this is a picture of
our mug here we go
so let's just move into the middle of it
there we are you can see the mug there
it's circular ish is it kind of a
cylinder and it's got a handle on it
okay that's as good as we can get from
that kind of resolution of camera that's
that far away from the mug you can see
that there's still some voxels that need
to be carved away that haven't and that
might just be because of the exact angle
of cameras that we used the more angles
you have the more you carve away the
closer objects to being the real object
but it's never going to get right quite
there and this is completely solid
okay it's not hollow because how would
we know what's hollar on what's not okay
and finally I'll move its cube which is
almost in some sense the worst of our
reconstructions because it's cubish
right but it's not it's not particularly
a cube
I mean that's cube kind of right but
this is the same shape that I was
pointing towards on my paper which is
that we can't really carve away these
bits very accurately 90-degree sides
like this do not lend themselves well to
space cup for example of one that does
work really really well
so in marketing and their distinguishing
between the size of tomato seedlings in
a factory so they're growing tomato
seedlings for sending out to the
greenhouses those of you who don't know
the Netherlands is big on greenhouses ok
there's loads of them I've flown over
them they're massive and they plant a
bunch of tomato seedlings and then they
very quickly classify them into
different classes and send them off to
different places depending on what
whether it be a Gore small or have you
and this is done incredibly quickly
space carving can do what 3d we can
suction takes quite a long time to do in
fractions of a second that's one of its
benefits it's very very quick so it's
rough and ready but it's quick laughs
and ready all you can dirty yeah right
so um so they've got 15 cameras all
we've gigabit network connections
streaming this data off and it's really
impressive it all happening in real time
so there are uses of space carving it's
just another interesting approach to 3d
reconstruction
I only asked him last night on a whim
can you just you know do this mug for me
and so it's it's you know it's small
it's low resolution but it gives you an
idea of what space carving does bison
bot bargaining and you have to you have
to get there correctly so it's in the
Netherlands nope okay and it's a place
full of plant scientists and other
researchers they do other things too
but we work with them quite closely on a
number of projects